[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars it's our
season finale of rogue theory
which means i'm back to get up
that's right we already had to drop a
bleep that's for you john costa
we're editing all year long uh it's our
final episode of 2020 which means
it's time that i make these people
pay for their theory crimes i've been
watching all season long
i've been screaming at my iphone
throwing it across rooms unrelated to
any of this i think some of you guys are
not going far enough down the multiverse
rabbit hole
some people have stupid theories about
which villains are coming back
somebody is just giving out rogies like
they're nothing and ruining the
inflation rate
yes those stupid sparkle bucks are worth
nothing you've crashed the economy of
sparkle mania
i'm philip molina and we've spent all
year predicting guessing and theorizing
about upcoming movies and tv shows here
in rogue theory
and for this the season finale we
brought back some of our
favorite favorite co-hosts to make the
case for their
rogus theories of the year the theories
to which we all said
holy [ __ ] that's a rogue so thought out
so fanservicey that kevin feige actually
might
steal this hopefully fingers crossed but
i'm not gonna do this alone
you know you can't have a judge panel
without having it mostly be white people
i'm bringing on uh off screen zack is
back on screen
uh and then we we have a bottom face app
uh santa on the on one side and a
top sand on the other with thomas
bechtel yes say hi my fellow judges
thank you phillip christmas is so
important to me philip i
uh it's a time to bring people together
and uh
celebrate with family and i just really
what
get out of here deadpool
oh my god is that was that the scale
oh are you
i wish uh no that was my uh
i don't know who that guy was to be
honest with me
our deadpool's been waiting in the
corner for how long
yeah the reality of this is that tommy
told his nephew to come do a fun bit
with him and then it's like he gets put
on a costume and all the bit was was
tommy yelled at him to get off the
screen
so i started on new rock stars it's the
same story
there are no small roles there are only
small relatives
all right and then who do we got on our
actual panel of course we have
mr eric voss from the rockstar oh the
courchesta
is now in control of the kingdom just
getting boss eyes ready
cool eric i think we missed some of that
seems like you glitched out for a second
uh we got
eric boss from new rockstars hello thank
you for having me on your program
uh eric foss from new rockstars uh i
came in with a big cactus
there he is that's the character he has
to stick with the whole episode
we also have comedian and writer jessica
clements
oh my voice crack but also
yeah congrats on puberty oh yeah thanks
oh my god that tree falling apart it did
a little bit
but don't tell my mom hello merry
christmas
happy holidays merry christmas mrs
clemens
um can jessica come on rogue theory all
right and then uh also we have comedian
writer erica wu
i don't have any christmas decorations
up or a christmas tree i don't celebrate
christmas but i do have my festivus
light post back there that's what i'm
celebrating 20 years
aluminum pole you got to do your airing
of your grievances
is it that the episode hasn't started
yet yeah i do my airing agreements
later but they're all boss related so
don't worry yeah
fair fun all right uh let's get to it
because people have waited all year
for this season finale episode that they
did not know was coming
so let's begin with eric voss
what theory have you brought before the
supreme
speculation court uh speculation
supreme court chief justice and
associate justices may it please the
court
i believe that's what they say um
so this is a theory that keeps bubbling
back up to the surface every episode of
rogue theory uh where i'm a panelist i
actually
pulled our lovely discord supporters
uh over what the crazy theory i've
speculated this
uh past year and it was a tie between
this and another theory that philip
already gave me a golden rogi for
not to brag too much earlier this year
this is my theory for how marvel will
open
up its multiverse starting with its
phase four titles um
and the spider verse it's all connected
and
it starts with wanda
i don't know why one division what the
no matter how hard you try i'm not gonna
do that the whole time i'm just kidding
oh my god
you almost lost retroactively lost your
golden road okay good good uh
tableau will handle the wrapping on
rogue theory i will just
drop a clip i am gonna subscribe
to disney plus there he is we miss him
okay
so one division my friends is a mere
weeks away
and it will be the dawn of marvel phase
four maybe they didn't plan it that way
but that's how kovid gods wanted it and
that's how we're gonna get it
uh it is going to be a story that shows
wanda maximov
living a series of hallucinatory sitcom
lives within a pocket reality that
appears to be projected from her own
reality warping powers she as we can see
in all trailer footage is trying to
invoke her love vision
back to life but i believe these visions
are not
vision he is dead the mind stone is
destroyed
so these visions a vision must be
taunts by a dimension that is actually
beneath our feet
the whole time hell two elves for this
hell
that is ruled over by my man mephisto
uh an entity that despite not so far
appearing in one division trailer
footage is technically mcu canon
thanks to a nearly impossible to spot
easter egg
in the first avengers movie on a shield
file they mentioned mephisto he's there
and he's here with us among us right now
so how do we get from there satan is
watching yes he has santa is watching he
sees you when you're sleeping knows when
you're awake
and he knows when you've been bad or
good in your body is manifesto supposed
to be santa
yes yeah it was a typo in an early comic
and they just
got it so all the
all the paperwork that was uh shield
paperwork is now sword paperwork and
sword is going to be in wanda vision
sword knows all about the threat from
miss
fisto uh because they are a sentient
world observation and response
department and what is a sentient world
other than hell
uh and now we learn that mephisto is the
one hijacking wanda maximoff's mind he
is trying to trick her with a
false dream life so that he can cross
over into this reality and run
amok uh in fact that version of monica
rambo that we see crashing through
the observation barrier that my friends
is actually
mephisto breaking free thus the devilish
smile
now uh this is all going to end in one
division after it's six episodes with
wanda
feeling betrayed bewildered she is
heartbroken
and she is going to suffer a psionic
meltdown
and just like in the house of m events
that this is clearly all based on she is
going to
shatter the reality that we know of the
mcu into various splinter
realities that is why one division will
be followed shortly after by the loki
series
that is going to feature based off his
jumpsuit the tva the time variance
authority
the uh governing body that looks over
alternate timelines and tries to
prevent crimes and investigate crimes
that's how
we're going to be able to keep a hold
we're going to see a nice hollow board
uh with owen wilson who's going to be
like oh kachow
wow oh wanda broke it over here but
oh we also got shang chiefs fighting in
a tournament
over here it's gonna make a lot of sense
because it's owen wilson
he's calming um now we're gonna move on
to the next
uh title on the mcu calendar spider-man
three
uh peter parker is uh eric i'm i'm sorry
counselor
if i can interrupt you just before we we
go too far
and and to my associate uh judges i i
want to point out
you can stop the council at any point in
his argument you may ridicule him
you may yell at him uh you may kiss his
uh
girlfriend on the lips those are the
only three things you may do
but i i want to know why does miss pisto
miss fisto why did miss brizzle uh
need wanda in order to cross over
you were talking about such a powerful
being i mean it seems like wanda is only
coming into her powers and yet he
desperately needs to put on a whole show
for her
well uh that is a very good question mr
chief justice
uh judge chief justice you forgot my
name who are you
the mephisto is banished to hell in the
same way that you could argue hell was
banished to
her corner of hell that just has one l
and they didn't realize another hell
already existed
uh he is banished to that side the same
way that dormammu can only occupy
occupy the uh dark dimension uh mephisto
needs a conduit of wanda maximoff
because she
can uh convert reality she can warp
reality and she is uh
while she is the most powerful avenger
she is also the most
vulnerable uh because she doesn't have
anyone to kind of explain to her what
her powers are so
through her he can use her to create
this kind of pocket reality that is not
a closed bubble but is actually a
gateway between worlds
only wanda maximoff can give him that
bridge between worlds
wanda is like a drunk operator of a
wrecking ball
smashing through also known as miley
cyrus
yeah all right lady cyrus
so um this nicely fits into what we know
of spider-man 3 that will feature
the sorcerer's supreme benedict
cumberbatch who is
also playing the source of supreme in a
fictional reality uh doctor strange
it's gonna appear in this movie and when
we last saw peter parker in
spider-man far from home he was freaked
out being outed as a spider-man
uh on big screens above
you know new york's penn station and
everyone's always looking at those
so he has to flee and where does he go
well he knows
not too far away from penn station in
manhattan you look at a map or if you're
in new york
you just swing on down eighth avenue
till you get to washington square
and then that is where 177a bleaker
street is he crashes through that
sanctum window
i'm sorry i'm gonna have to pause you
right there judge thomas
um objection yeah
great thank you uh uh for waking up
and joining us eric just gave us a lot
of
geography for new york now residing
in new york state yourself yes uh how
accurate was his geography there because
we could throw his whole case out
well phillip i have been to new york
city twice
in my life i have been to toronto a
hundred and thirty times
so as a expert not only is those regions
let me just tell you uh rochester new
york is a bit of a grid
okay there is the city of rochester and
outlining that is greece and henrietta
and irondequoit great that's great
these are nowhere near manhattan
literally seven or eight hours away but
i'm getting there
uh just past webster is ontario and a
little bit east of ontario is oswego
county
oswego is where jerry seinfeld went to
college and where i attended college
as well as al roker we continue uh south
of that is
mexico new york but not before you have
to pass through egypt new york just as
time your way to poultneyville
[Music]
um okay so i literally muted tummy oh my
god
wow what happened to democracy this is
absolutely a hell in the cell right here
guys um i see chief justice zach is
taking notes
so i will try to be consistent uh going
forward so
why would you bring doctor strange into
a movie if you aren't going to explore
his multiverse hopping powers is dr
strange just gonna like teach peter
parker magic tricks and balloon animals
no no no my friends
he is going to introduce peter into this
crisis created by
wanda maximov in which realities are
splintered
and all kinds of chaos is happening
because now the real problem for peter
parker is that he
is being targeted am i muted
no just kidding guys did you guys think
i was really muted
what is reality i am the sorcerer's
supreme because
these judges are so wise excuse me
what oh my god miss clements do you have
something to say
how'd you unmute yourself um okay
so um peter is being targeted by
sinister six villains from different
realities in the spider-verse to me that
is the clearest explanation for how
jamie foxx electro is coming into this
story
uh even if he is different uh slightly
different looking than um
dr manhattan as he was in the amazing
spider-man 2 he's going to be in this
movie there's even rumors that alfred
molina as doc
ock is going to appear in this movie as
well each of these
objections objection i really hope that
happened
yes i really really hope that sustained
um
objection objection i don't want that to
happen because i wanted to be katherine
hahn i wanted to be olivia hey
why not both
so uh because this sinister six from
different
corners of the spider verse are now
targeting each of their respective peter
parkers
that's what dr strange is going to help
peter parker with
he is going to form an alliance of
live-action peter parker's
and maybe even an animated miles morales
we're going to see a toby maguire peter
parker cameo in there and we are going
to see an andrew garfield i would even
argue that we have already seen a clue
of andrew garfield peter parker because
in the one image we've seen as of this
taping tom holland's set photo there
is a specific gloved sleeve in that
frame that is exactly what andrew
garfield is wearing as his peter parker
in both of his movies
you mean this this kind of sleeve yeah
one with the gloves with a hole for the
thumb
um so just a glove just uh
or like a freak a sweatshirt so
uh it's gonna end with uh that uh crisis
briefly solved on peter parker's corner
it might even set up a gwen stacey and a
miles morales live action in this
universe hopefully
caleb mclaughlin playing miles morales
would be great but i know there are lots
of great options that are out there
now i gotta wonder if he's upset where
we just lost this threat of wanda maxima
oh no
my friend because we still have the
finale of this multiverse crisis
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness a story that will be directed by
sam raimi himself king of the
spider-verse
who knew that dr strange was in this
world back
in spider-man 2 so he's going to direct
the post-credits scene
of spider-man 3 that is going to set up
this multiverse crisis
you're going to see wanda maximoff and
all of her fiery glory
uh that is in the midst of a multiverse
crisis
she is going to be the villain of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness we
already know from kevin feige that she's
going to be
in this movie but the issue is is doctor
strange is not going to want to destroy
her
because he doesn't want to do any harm
he took a hippocratic
oath and in fact that oath has informed
his entire
uh mo as a doctor in
marvel comics the oath is one of his
most famous comics
uh that they definitely used to inspire
the first doctor strange movie
however his uh antagonist in addition to
wanda
is going to be mordo baron mordo who
ended the first doctor strange saying
too many sorcerers one of those
sorcerers wanda maximoff he
is going to be hopping through the
multiverse trying to kill her doctor
strange is gonna be in a race against
him
to get to her first so he can try to
heal her not kill her
he's gonna need some help though in
addition to people like wong he's gonna
have
america chavez the uh star
kicking badass who's gonna hop through
the multiverse
and it's gonna help doctor strange i
believe she has already been cast zochi
gomez right
so it's gonna throughout this journey
strange is gonna be teaming up with
various alternate reality avengers we're
gonna see captain britain who has teased
in avengers end game
we're going to see a new wolverine uh
we're going to start to maybe plant some
seeds for the illuminati with doctor
strange
we might even see my friends alternate
sorcerers supreme including tony stark
as an alternate source of supreme robert
downey jr showing back they already have
uh footage that they shot for infinity
war that they could just drag and drop
in this movie of him in the cloak of
levitation and you know that marvel
decides based on
the footage they have in their dropbox
right that's how they piece
these together um so doctor strange is
gonna end
with a kind of mind battle with wanda
it's going to be kind of like imagine a
chess
match with the two of them uh going back
and forth to try to uh
settle her mind and bring her back home
and it's gonna happen with a no more
mutants convergence
uh where all these alternate realities
are gonna converge onto one reality
uh and uh she's gonna say whatever no
more
whatever it is and in the end it doesn't
even matter
but post credit scene my friends doctor
strange is going to wake up in this
combined reality
and the chess match that he is in is not
with wanda maximoff
he raises his eyes to meet those of
professor charles xavier
who moves the whites and says
shall we begin but and he doesn't know
who that guy is though
uh he says i'm professor charles xavier
he's like howie mandel i'm a huge fan
uh i'm professor xavier i'm going to be
very important
uh my name is sister professor is
someone he might meet
in his uh journey across the multiverse
and he realized that there's this other
guy who's kind of a
similar figure who's just up the river
in westchester county
uh and they're old friends now and now
westchester county is right near
albany albany is next to schenectady
which is where they do the lottery
okay so eric
tommy has to keep on meeting himself
so rude i just love that i have the
control to mute him
um okay so eric uh uh well actually
first uh just as zach
do you did you actually write anything
useful or i didn't believe i mean
this is mostly a shopping list for later
but i do have a few uh observations
there eric
first off i love your referencing of uh
mordo's too many sorcerers how is that
not the subtitle of the second
uh doctor strange movie too many sources
anyways
you mentioned a lot of great characters
including mephisto
playing a huge role in these upcoming
properties who's
who's your casting do you think do you
believe that evan peters
uh rumors there that that's the role
he's gonna be playing in one division
i i i do mr associate justice i do think
evan peters would make a fantastic
methisto
uh and they could even work in a cameo
with his quick silver because if
mephisto is a devil and the devil takes
many forms
he could shapeshift into his just
briefly
uh a version of quicksilver just to with
wanda
are we are we referencing she's like who
the hell is this i it's a guy from
american horror story season one
yeah and that's my brain that's the
version of uh of mephisto i want to see
you want to see the dark evan peters
from uh american horror story
as opposed to uh peter maxima from the
fox x-men movies
uh all right well we're all in on this
theory uh
now eric um while the uh associate
justices and i confer
i'd like to ask you to remove your
headphones so that we can go into
private
uh deliberation thank you oh he's naked
right now
no no eric all right so uh
what do you guys think i mean uh a lot
of detail certainly and pretty pretty
big
a lot of pretty pretty expansive theory
uh
love the inclusion of mephisto but if he
said his name one more time he was going
to see my fists
you know right i feel the same way about
that rhyme
yeah i thought it was
it was well researched it was
exhaustively reported literally
um my one knock i mean he mentioned so
many marvel properties
no love for the eternals is he thinking
that's gonna be a total
uh one-off kind of offshoot that will
have no repercussions
afterwards i think that was the the big
flaw in his argument he's
threatening me via text right now
he's reading lips i can see him i can't
uh and my and my issue
though i think i kind of want to give
him one chance on this is how cowardly
was his she says no more something or
other
yeah and he didn't decide what that noun
was
now let's give him one chance if he has
a good uh
if he sticks the landing here he's back
in on fire then then he's back in but
right now he's on my [ __ ] list
eric you can put your uh headphones on
yep yes
we the uh associate justices and i
um have one follow-up question uh you
have five seconds to answer it when
you're ready
are you ready go ahead all right uh one
of our our big issues
is uh you had wanna maximoff explain
exclaim an iconic line
and yet you did not tell us what she
actually says so what did she say
no more what oh five she says no
more multiverse
all right tommy you're cut off tommy we
can't see you
no no no no oh my tommy's body is great
it's phillips crotch
all right um that's what i believe they
do in the supreme court and then the
somebody burst out the doors and they're
like he said no more multiverse
and people start screaming and cheering
exactly
that uh black and white man cries um
okay
all right uh eric a great job uh
fantastic
work uh as you know just like the
supreme court we won't tell you whether
or not you won until uh three to six
months from now
um but uh in the meantime we're going to
talk about uh
some other winners uh and that's
specifically hellofresh is our big
winner
uh of sponsoring this episode guys
hellofresh is awesome actually
uh you can get fresh pre-measured
ingredients and mouth-watering seasonal
recipes delivered right to your door
with hellofresh
america's number one meal kit hellofresh
lets you skip those trips to the grocery
store that nobody wants to be making
right now i'm not doing any of these
right now
instead you just do home cooking which
is easy but it's fun and affordable when
you do it through them
the recipes are really easy to follow
eric managed to do one
very recently yeah how'd you do eric i i
uh
took the knife and i took the fork and i
went smash smash smash smash and i
turned on the stove
and then uh food went in my mouth it was
delicious this is a true story uh when i
used to live with eric he
uh decided he was gonna start cooking to
be healthier and he literally he just
learned how to
bake pizza dough and make pizzas for
everything he made the pizza
instead of defrosting the pizza
all the cheese i wanted that's when you
gained like 45 pounds that summer
uh but he wouldn't do that if he had
just used hellofresh uh they got simple
steps and pictures that would have
guided him along the way
hello versus streamlined supply chain
means produce gets to you faster
and fresher than it gets to the grocery
store which is so mean to the grocery
stores
but yeah i mean do they need it uh i
personally really enjoyed working with
hello fresh recipes that i made i'm
crazy busy all the time and it's nice to
be able to just get like a really
delicious
pretty healthy dinner quickly without
needing to rummage through my fridge and
just like force some things together
they just tell me everything
you can easily change your delivery days
or meal plan preferences and skip a week
whenever you need right on the
hellofresh app
go to hellofresh.com rogue 90. remember
rogue is not spelled rouge everyone look
at the name of the show
rogue r-o-g-u-e-90
use code rogue 90 to get 90 off
including free shipping on that food
before those greedy grocery stores get
it 90 off free shipping uh use code
rogue90 hellofresh.com
rogue90. tommy uh what kind of meal do
you have prepared for
uh christmas oh for christmas i've
already started baking my special pie
i'm friends with a local barber who has
had a series of mishaps lately
and has been uh let's just say clumsy
with disposing of the bodies
and ice cubes simple solution it's ice
cube and omar gooding
and uh keenan thompson as well uh was
omar getting in that movie i can't
remember
i don't know you better be right uh yeah
the internet will drag me uh i was
thinking of kevin thompson for some
reason said omar gooding which is not
even close
anyway cuda thompson's uh also helping
me with my bakery and
uh we're also gonna have a ham we're
gonna have a ham okay great that could
have been the answer
um hey john we'll try this great
question phillip
i am going to have a ham
that's awesome hang on let me try that
one more time i've killed before
okay great and we here at new rockstars
have killed before
uh no uh you know what killed before uh
was game of thrones
but the only thing that we're happy to
go back and do is watch it on mute and
look at those glorious glorious sweet
beards on that show oh i thought you
were gonna say boobs
those two those hairy boobs uh and those
hairy northerners they could have uh
they could probably especially with the
hairy boobs used our wonderful sponsor
manscaped
eric do you are you manscaping right now
there you are yeah yeah doing it right
now
your midscape yeah uh
let the hair escape from your man don't
talk to me with manscape
yeah the lawnmower 3.0 trimmer could
have helped prevent
nicks and cuts that eric has suffered
for years uh westeros has also seen
enough bloodshed already
so the new lawnmower 3.0 is waterproof
with advanced skin safe technology and
they even have a light to help you shave
everywhere
they've also just if you want to shave
in the dark and be real creepy about it
they've also got the weed whacker ear
and nose hair trimmer
to make sure your facial hair doesn't
you know trespass that
north of the lip wall uh if you got
smelly feet
manscape can help you with their foot
duster foot deodorant landscape is just
trying to make men do right by their
women or other men actually
and just anything that they can do to
fight the odor on those real funky feet
like sandor clegane level funk
uh you want to smell good everywhere the
refined cologne by manscape is clean and
percent
designed for the refined gentleman guys
would you like twenty percent off and
free shipping huh
yes always great yes
could you send me one of those ear and
nose hair trimmers
my crotch has been naturally hairless
since birth but my
ears and nose are just an absolute rough
patch right now i gotta say i'm hitting
with a pitching wedge
and i'd love to be using one of my long
irons so wow
that's great uh well tommy you can order
those yourself
if you use the code rogue theory at
manscape.com
you'll get 20 off 100 off of your nose
problems but 20
off your order and free shipping that's
20 off free shipping at manscape.com use
code rogue
theory be sure to join the manscape
movement it's a movement people
uh these products are snow joke
zach wrote that joke you know what i
like it i like it i feel like you do all
of these
i like that the last one was a seasonal
winter joke and the rest of it was about
game of thrones game of thrones
winter oh jon snow winter is coming
once i found out i wasn't gonna get an
ear trimmer on the house i really shut
down emotionally
yeah tommy what does the bottom of your
sweater say gangsta what
rapper oh i get it now yeah
yeah i don't love it but it was
aesthetically the best looking one at
walmart
there was one that there was one that
was a t-shirt that was a pissed off
garfield
and it just it with a thought bubble
that just said so what it's christmas
and that's like what it looked like he
was thinking
i really wanted to get that one but i
thought it didn't just
go with you know my mobile personality
so i
i i confused that image of garfield with
uh like on the back of a truck the
the christmas grump movie poster
the christmas basket this year on
hallmark
on sci-fi a christmas john go ahead and
photoshop that for us
all right can we blur tommy out soon
can we fly on marina masteros to uh fill
in first out with the wrestling upset
can we also blur zach's pen fetish
i
well jessica why don't you take over
then with what theory
you dare to bring before the court i
have a theory that has so many holes you
guys will have to interrupt me
so much don't threaten us with a good
time yeah i'm threatening you i'm
throwing you with the
uh the best time all right look at those
holes let's see them hauls
when um get in the comments so when you
when you guys reached out to me about
this i was like not only do i love this
topic not only do i want to talk about
it all the time
uh so much so that i wrote two pages of
notes for it
so i'm gonna damn i'm gonna try and keep
this brief
jessica i gotta tell you there is a a
rule on rogue theory whenever you show
that you took notes you're no longer
allowed to use your notes
i can try i can try give me i will look
at
nothing oh okay let me try let me try
let me try all right if i look down it's
because my zipper is undone it's not
because i'm looking at these people
great and i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
pull it back up so
last time i was on uh last time the
theory that i like to pitch
that was when i was a young sapling was
how the next avengers movie
villain would be doctor doom and doctor
doom would be played by giancarlo
esposito and i still stand by it because
that man is hot and so is doctor doom
get at me so what does he look like
john carlo no doctor dude he's got metal
skin
he wears that metal skin and that cape
and that
is attractive yes and microwaves but we
will talk about that enough she's got a
parking meter fetish she likes upright
vacuum cleaners all i'm saying is this
black friday i was online
shopping i was on it
so this is my first hole how hot is
doctor training
so i love when a woman tells me here's
my first hole
doctor doom and then that's what she
calls it
that's so fun i'm gonna do that so
doctor doom is gonna be the villain
and in what capacity what the [ __ ] is he
gonna be doing
i'm sorry john what is he gonna be doing
he's gonna be
fighting in secret wars so i love secret
wars and when i say i love secret wars
i'm talking about
the 1980s version and the 2015 issue i'm
not talking about secret wars 2
where beyonder comes back down to earth
though that is very fun
i'm not about it so i think in my
opinion
that oh um my zipper's down oh my gosh
oh no
so there's
there's something was real funny down
there there's three ways we can handle
this so we're gonna say i'm gonna talk
about how it can be done
how disney will do it because it will
make them so much money
and i'm going back to my notes i'm sorry
i lied to you
uh why doctor doom would replace replace
beyonder in my opinion
are we going to get a secret war summary
here yeah oh i guess i should i should
give you guys one
so basically nineteen notes
i didn't write this one day i didn't
write that down so i think i guess i
could say it
um okay so over time my secret wars 1984
where like it was
basically oh i'm trying not to spoil
well i'll just jump down to my third one
why disney will make a lot of money off
of it secret war is the first one in
1984
was created for merchandising completely
and
all that it was for they were like how
are we going to sell and pitch these
villains no one wants a super villain
unless
they are on alongside with a bunch of
superheroes so
they made secret wars essentially and it
turned out to be a hit
so disney would make a lot more money
from doing secret wars because they have
all that merchandise that can come with
it
when we saw baby yoda we immediately
googled how to purchase baby yoda
and then there goes build-a-bear
creating baby yoda
so of course disney's like secret wars
all these villains all these heroes
cha-ching money all the disney execs
right now their ears are going real
quick uh
just a very easy uh disgusting shout out
to the baby yoda name reveal shirt
available on
epic hero shop.com
uh easy shameless plug plugins continue
just to get
it i love it and i hope they do a gender
reveal for yoda too like i i i
for baby did you see alderaan
it's frown
[Music]
so secret war is the 1980s version all
the uh heroes essentially just pop up on
this planet they were in the middle of
doing their own tasks some were in the
kitchen some were
i'm making this up somewhere in the
toilet some were honestly just catching
the bus
and then all of a sudden they wound up
on this planet they don't know how they
got there on the other side of the
planet are the villains
and it's every villain you can think of
and every superhero you can think of
scratch that it's the most popular ones
that would make money because again
this was for merchandise they're not
gonna pull out some crazy
weirdo that no one wants to see they're
only gonna bring out the stunts
so they brought them all out they
brought out uh
galactus they brought out ultron and it
was insane
how these people fought because only one
for each team
was fighting for actual reasons everyone
was like let's kill the villains
let's kill the heroes and there we got
doom and we have captain america that
are like
that's not what we should do we should
try figuring out why we're on this
planet
and then it just goes to chaos the 2015
issue
they wind up on this planet their
memories are wiped completely
and dr doom is the god of the planet and
essentially that's all you need to know
because
it gets crazy from there that's where we
get the zombies
and we get just like a bunch of hulks
and a bunch of thor's and i love it
thank you
thank you that was my secret summary
very good i was partially distracted by
eric's own reflection behind him that i
i just realized back there that's just
my one brother he just likes to watch me
do my thing
tell him to sit up straight he's got bad
posture right it's it's been 31 years
i'm sorry
okay so i did look at my notes again i'm
sorry
oh no i was trying to vamp for you oh my
god i shouldn't have said anything
so no objection to objection objection
do any of the hulks
kiss while they're on the plane i will
say yes
so like ray hulk and redhawk might yeah
i'll be here for it will disney be here
for it can
can you give us a full summary of grey
hulk and red hulk's relationship over
the years and how it's changed in the
nuances
and how they're on secret war now and
they're just
uh there's a lot of them and then they
just kiss
great all right
and then they smooch i don't know where
else they just go it's okay
they do weird they're doing great sex
things i don't know what do you want
from me tommy
that's not what i why why is this on me
i just asked a big kiss
you went to weird tommy i muted tommy
okay
so how we can do it so
we have i think that we should be
pulling which i did say this in the
first
row theory where i brought these all up
that we should combine both the 2015
issue and the 1980s issue because we
have dr doom who's a god
who literally rips out the spine and
head from thanos
in the 2015 issue just and then we have
all the thor's and we have all the hulks
and the thor's are just policemen of
this
uh of battle world i think we should
pull from that
but we should use the chaoticness from
the 1984 version
where he has all the power in the world
where he basically destroys
he doesn't really but essentially beats
beyond her
so i think if we have those two issues
put together
we can get what i'm talking about and
now
jessica this is this is very delightful
i'm just gonna
point out you have a huge appearance of
beyond her you have a huge appearance of
doctor doom
from what i'm understanding these
characters just suddenly show up
in the mcu i'm gonna can i say
my trailer oh please i was gonna follow
it with the trailer okay
let's try the two-parter we love those
two part of movies
both are two and a half hours long too
long for one movie so it's gonna be a
two-parter
we have a bunch of people in new york of
course eating lunch at a little diner a
little bistro whatever you want to call
it they're all enjoying their nice day
and then all of a sudden the skies get
dark the ground starts to shake
everyone stands up what what's going on
a whole
just blares out in the middle of the
street sinking all the cars
a child's falling one of those major
holes it's like an earthquake but it's
not
and when the child is falling through
he's like mom they're like
and it cuts to an underground bunker
where nick fury's standing there looking
at monitors of all these things
happening around the world
and here comes anthony mackie running in
and he goes
tell me why an earthquake just sank all
of queens
and nick fury goes that's no earthquake
cut back to the scene of the crime here
comes doctor doom stomping in
and he goes read show yourself and
everyone's just confused and screaming
and then out from the sky drops captain
marvel and she goes
i was all the way by the milky way but i
ain't no reed and then she's about to
fight and here comes spider-man who's
like i'm about to join in
thor comes in he's like what's going on
and then behind doctor doom we see
enchantress
we see volcano we see kang the conqueror
and it's too soon in this trailer for so
many people to appear out of nowhere we
haven't even seen some of these people
what's going on a giant beam of light
shows up and from the point of view of
thor his eyes close
open and they're on a decaying world
where nothing is living it's just
disgust
and when he opens his eyes he looks
around he sees heroes that we haven't
seen in mcu yet
we see heroes that were dead once but
now they're back
and then we see some heroes that are
just what the [ __ ] am i doing here
and then on the other side of the planet
we have these here these super villains
that open their eyes to a foresty grassy
meadow
and they're like what's going on that's
when the trailer goes black i have to
look at my notes for this part because i
quoted it the screen goes black
and all we hear is i am from beyond slay
your enemies and all you desire shall be
yours
and it goes avengers
i guess you call it four
[Laughter]
and then i guess you say five i guess
you would call it because you call it
fantastic
i gave you too much of a trailer that
you got to pay me disney for the title
so that's what you're going to get so i
don't know if that completely answered
your question of we have all these
people showing up
my question was did you really just
bring in huge characters and give them
no backstory and you answered it with
adding 10 more characters
yes we brought in suddenly with no
backstory i like the balls on you
uh jessica will you please take off your
headset oh my god of course
i mean i say we call it right here i
think we got a senator
for life i think she needs life in
prison for that
no possibility um which is not
necessarily a bad thing
you did free free food yeah and the
jails that i've designed are more like
fun houses torture chambers if you will
i have a lot in my yay and my neigh
column here uh
as far as the a's who wouldn't won
yeah uh who wouldn't want
giant you know uh mortal kombat-esque
uh battles between a ton of heroes and a
ton of villains
i also think it's a fun way to introduce
a lot of characters i'll give her credit
for that
like just throw them into this and like
we just
see a uh a kanga conqueror doing crazy
things and like
it's almost to tease for future
properties of course like i think philip
you did a
uh you pointed out rightly the mcu
famous for taking multiple movies to
establish
characters and not necessarily throwing
dozens at us in the course of one
uh that that's going to be tough to get
over but i i love the gusto
so after schenectady new york you get uh
just a little bit further
for this there's a bit of a no it's a
bit of a no-man's plan
all right uh jessica go ahead and bring
your headphones
back up headset jessica yep she's just
she goes
eyes up yeah that's it
this was a bad idea
how long were you guys doing that i'm
sorry well tommy's still going as you
can tell
i think he's doing tommy i see you
seasons of love in
american sign language um all right
jessica
uh we think it was very ballsy we
were very impressed with with a lot of
what you brought and we're
very excited for uh that terrible movie
poster that would have to fit that whole
name on it um
we you know there was consensus that it
does feel like uh the mcu might not jump
directly to
something like that but hey you know
what jessica
it's rogue theory it is also
i'm all about it let me look at my notes
i put in bold i'm assuming this is after
wanda vision and
because she got her powers in one
division and fantastic four movie coming
soon
i was i put so much weird [ __ ] in it but
it is road feeling i love though that uh
uh
how many like prominent lines are given
to people we have no idea who they are
a man that comes out he's dr doom and he
screams read show yourself and we're
like we don't know either of you
the people at the little bistro are like
what the [ __ ] we love it oh those people
that's a little kid that was falling
into the hole
[Laughter]
it's tommy bistro
oh oh great all right guys uh well
that's uh pretty exciting i don't know
if a wuzu's gonna be able to top that
oh ye of little faith yeah
uh i just want to let you guys know that
uh there are there is something on the
line here the winner
of our you know supreme court cases only
one person wins
um the government uh and rich people
just but aside from
yeah lady lady liberty i just want to
give a quick shout out to the new
rockstars merch store
that is where our prize is going to come
from uh whoever wins gets any item from
the new rockstars merch store
shipped to them free of charge with just
the price of the item and shipping
uh it's not too late to end 2020 right
with some
super cool merch we got hats we got
shirts hoodies
masks we got that silly hi i'm eric voss
shirt that is really confusing people
when
the little kids are wearing it and
they're being picked up uh or not picked
up because they
have their own name on them what would
uh you know the three of you who are
up here um in in in the in the running
for winning
what are you thinking about getting
yourself from the store if you win
well i really like new rockstars as
apparel uh
especially the new rockstar speedo male
thong for swimming
i think it'll really spice up my winner
and i'll go into 2021
that much more stylish with it on yeah
that was unrelated yeah uh just real
quick that speedo
uh does make you infertile but if that's
what you're going for wouldn't be the
first time
all right that's less mcu tip movie
tickets i gotta buy in the future
so bring it on there you go
uh jessica what are you looking for um i
kind of want the eric
boss shirt because i want to be a child
that doesn't get picked up
or to commit crimes and get away with
them i'm eric voss as soon as some
robber
it's gonna be like uh the pelican brief
no what's that movie called the
um the one with pierce brosnan and
there's several pierce brosnan's and
they say that was crown affair thomas
crown affair it's all just a bunch of
eric boss is trying to steal a painting
uh and eric what do you want
uh i want the uh new rockstars merch
store
version of the vaccine because i can't
get on the wait list for pfizer or
madarina's
uh and but if i can get real quick just
so you know the vaccine the vaccine
causes fertility
uh so you know cool give it to tommy or
like a waxing
don't encourage this nobody wants the
new rock stars of
bombers yeah
i love bombs yeah she did and that's
all right guys uh so make sure to check
out the rockstar's merch store
newarkstarsmerge.com uh to get yourself
whatever these uh
people these winners and losers are
gonna get uh
and then real quick uh before we move on
to our final theory we did something
really fun on our discord
alright our discord is for new rockstars
patrons and
as we've been wrapping up this season of
rogue theory on the channel
they've been actually wrapping up a
season of internal rogue theory on the
discord
where they play against each other and
we did the playoffs
and now all year has led to this
from our patreon discord we have the
winner of
our rogue theory discord playoff series
uh
all the winners came back but this was
the one theory
that takes the grand prize of getting to
pitch their theory
right here on the show john play the
tape
hi guys pharaoh jeff here for the new
rockstars discord server pitching my
theory that won the rogue theory
tournament
our prompt was from john james and he
asked us to pitch a movie based off a
board game such as battleship
or clue after surviving attack that cost
him his family and puts his best friend
into a coma
willem dafoe wakes up in a hospital
surrounded by detectives and the lead
detective is played by jamie foxx
jimmy fox asked him a question but we
find out that willem dafoe can't
actually speak
he can only communicate by drawing
pictures the nurse introduces him as
peter pictionary jamie foxx is actually
able to go from location location based
off the clues he's guessing from
pictionary's drawings
we find out in the end the true culprits
are actually the parker brothers who
kidnap peter pictionary
at the climax of the movie it actually
seems as if the parker builders are
going to win
but the detective gets a call from the
hospital telling him that his best
friend woke up from her coma
but she can't speak either she can only
communicate in wild gestures
the nurse then introduces her to him as
sharon charades
and the credits roll hey
wow very good better than any of you any
of you myself included
give it up one more time for our patreon
discord rogue theory champion
any item from the new rockstars merch
store sent to that person with uh at
full price with cost of shipping
all right i'm saying that
all right thanks to everybody who
participated in the contest if you guys
want to be part of future events like
that just go ahead and join our discord
community by becoming a patron
at patreon.com new rockstars finally
eric one
erica wusu all right everyone
yeah what have you to offer the supreme
speculation clerk
well thank you your highness majesty uh
the honorable uh
respectable high court justice of the
land stop sucking up
no one likes a brown dozer we love it
it's too late my nose is already brown
that doesn't count
that doesn't count for the win for the
win
so boss is the only one that loses
by default okay so
uh phase four and phase five are going
to be
gnarly and we're kicking it off as eric
voss said with
wander vision i like to call the
wanderer vision because i have a
midwestern accent
now so in wanda vision and to see that
face that jessica looks at me
so i want division um yes the big baddie
will be mephisto who will be played by
evan peters who played
quicksilver beat let's get eric boss's
theory back out here
but i think he's going to be a bigger
more integral part of phase four
uh than eric vos thought or said i think
he's going to create a lot of mischief
all throughout the multiverse in the mcu
coming up for our heroes to do battle
against
so i think well my big theory that uh
you guys liked from this year
was that in one division mephisto
uh comes in he tears things apart uh
he's created this hell
for wanda to be in uh torturing her with
the memories of
vision making her think that she can
bring vision back and the vision is
there and they have kids involved the
whole nine
i think that still happens but i think
also in the process
mephisto will create the ghost writer
okay the ghost writer the ghost ghost
writer
coast ghost writer not the one who wrote
the script yes
the ghost writer no not that ghost rider
starring samuel jackson who now nick
fury which would be
actually really fun okay well okay
my mind just now and not agents of
shield
ghost writer no no we need so much
clarity on this ghostwriter
it's not even funny ghost rider is a
marvel superhero
uh in the movies that fox and marvel
made back in the day he was played by
nicholas cage
he's a guy on a motorcycle with a black
leather jacket and a skull that's on
fire that's ghost riding
right so he's a marvel hero kind of
anti-hero
uh who was created by mephisto because
mephisto uh
got his soul uh in exchange for life and
super power so he could save his family
member blah blah blah the classic deal
with the devil that we all make
there it is so mephisto is created ghost
rider he will be
in the mcu and my big theory was that he
will be
played by nicholas cage once again in
the mcu now
and later down the line when there is
the new spider-man movie and there's
all the spider-men from all over the
multiverse one of such
who was in miles morales spider-man into
the spider-verse
was spider-man noir who was voiced by
nicholas cage
so at some point during this mcu phase
four
ghost rider played by nicholas cage is
going to
run into spiderman noir voice acted by
nicholas cage and they will have a big
face-off
in this marvel movie coming up that i'm
not sure which one will happen probably
in the spider-man movie so yeah eric
your this your whole case hinges on this
yes okay
we need to hear that scene between
nicholas cage spider-man noir facing
off against nicholas cage ghost writer
in nicholas cage voice i will give you
two options
you can perform this yourself or you can
assign it to either of your fellow
panelists whichever
you think is gonna turn out better for
you making them look bad making yourself
look good
or bad what do you think thank you your
honorable justice majesty
all right now i will play nicholas cage
playing ghost rider
and i will have tommy bechdel plays
no no no one on the judge's uh uh
why can't i be here
you look at the experience you're
robbing us off tommy's doing a elizabeth
olsen impression up there
but we need it okay from your
contestants okay i will pick eric voss
to be nicholas cage playing spider-man
noir okay
okay so i will face off scene ah yes i
will kick us off as
ghost rider and you will respond as
spider-man are you ready
yeah let's do it okay all those years of
improv here we go
wasted
so many hundreds we all know okay
here i am now who are you
who are you yeah you look like me or you
sound like me
well no you sound like me except less
fiery
oh i saw my wife die what happened to
your wife
she's chilling in the house but i'm on
fiery because my
father is trapped in hell all right real
quick uh uh and boss is your version of
nicholas cage on like a window cleaning
thing
wait who's through that window that's
justice tommy back told
who looks like a peach for hours
elizabeth olsen
all right uh thank you very much classic
face-off
uh ironically a face-off scene not
featuring face-off nicholas cage
uh eric please uh take back your your
theory and bring it home
oh my god okay so is that what that was
it seemed like uh
doc back to the future like
everyone gets electrocuted
so okay so mephisto has more mischief to
stir up
because he also is involved with one
the silver surfer and now in another
theory i brought up earlier in the year
the silver surfer surfer oh god
cancelled forget it
right there with my first though now the
silver softer
will skate over to earth because after
the at the end of the deadpool 3 movie
my theory for that movie is that
deadpool will be tasked with
assassinating professor xavier
uh by a mysterious figure so he'll go to
war against the x-men and when they
don't all kill each other
they realize they have the same common
enemy uh who
is revealed to be mojo the big yellow
gross
intergalactic tv host personality alien
person
i love this but i have a question am i
allowed to ask questions oh you could
have been tearing each other apart the
whole time
i was trying the only ruthless enough
one jessica clemens um
first off this stinks um
no but so critic you said yeah you said
at the end of deadpool 3 that he's going
to be tasked
to kill xavier well so
that would be the beginning catalyst of
deadpool 3.
can you give me like the tie in between
deadpool 2
and that catalyst then because why is he
working with the x-men at the end of
deadpool 2 so clearly and they're in
love with
like colossus and everybody and then now
they're going to kill xavier i don't
understand why he would do that
i'll tag in time travel time travel
hey i didn't ask you
uh to be fair eric [ __ ] off okay
she didn't ask you no she did
[Laughter]
that's the answer for everything every
time someone writes themselves into a
corner
time travel all right uh who's gonna
play the silver surfer
yes okay so yes so
has a tie in with the silver server
because in the comic books mephisto
wants to take the silver surfer's soul
that's one of his big missions in the
comic book so that'll be his mission
uh and their main battle in the mcu
movies coming coming up uh
also mephisto in the comic books
captured the silver surfers lover so
that'll play into the movies and that'll
be kind of the ransom situation the
silver surfer will have to decide
whether or not he trades his own soul to
mephisto
for his lover that he uh
sacrificed himself to take on the mantle
of silver surfer
to protect way back in the day when
galactus
uh threatened his own planet so he's the
lover
the lover i'm glad you asked because i
have an answer for you
yes the lover's name is jessica clemens
uh since the silver surfer's lover
is named shala bao they have weird alien
names
so charlo ball is is uh silver surfer's
lover
so another character introduced yeah i'm
gonna call if i called out jessica ford
i have to call you out for it too
there's a lot of new characters that we
might not care about
i'll say the character that we know the
most
is just mephisto theoretically
may appear in wanda vision now
it's i i'm gonna say you're off on a
limb here but
uh i'm gonna reserve my opinion for
how you're then implying that one
division ends if
afterward mephisto is still out and
about
running amok so one division ends
with wanda splitting the mo
the universe into a multiverse a
multiverse
of madness and that's where later down
the line
uh doctors have to put everything he has
to put everything back together
so it doesn't end happily juan division
it just kind of sets everything up to
get shattered into a million different
fragments
so that we have the live-action kind of
spider-man is the spider-verse
multiverse mini spider-man
and that's how we get the x-men being
brought into this universe
uh the eternals will probably have
something to do with all the
intergalactic baddies and and celestial
beings fighting over control of things
you know now let's learn from zach being
mad that eric didn't bring up the
eternal i took notes myself
i brought up cosmic entities yes
energies so since you know the
infinity stones are pretty much no
longer in play
they got to figure out a way to have all
this intergalactic
space travel high-flying uh cowboy stuff
happen
and so this is how it'll happen with
wanda shattering the universe into the
multiverse
will the can i ask a question will the
uh switching tv channels of wanda vision
be what triggers
mojo's network like he's got whatever
his satellite
tv and he's like he's messing with me
yeah
that's how he comes across like these uh
frequencies
i like it yes yes anytime wanda decides
to change the channel with a nose wiggle
just like elizabeth montgomery
then that's that's when mojo notices
that channels are being changed and
reality is being messed with yeah
he's like the neighboring poltergeist
he's like stop flipping the child
yeah uh we all watched poltergeist
recently uh okay uh and uh justice says
uh uh zach and tommy do you have any
follow-up questions for
uh councilman yes i don't did we get an
answer to tommy's question about who's
gonna play silver surfer
oh i didn't even catch that question um
i haven't started to answer it
uh my answer for who will play the
silver surfer
is carrot top he's gonna shave his curly
red locks
[Music]
you know the fact that there's a carrot
top
implies that there's also a carrot
bottom and for me
okay i'm into it i don't know versatile
carrots are where it's at
uh uh zach any questions for you
uh i loved it when when in the in the
upcoming timeline
this now you this great battle between
silver surfer and mephisto
is this in a silver surfer movie like a
standalone movie or
where what property is this taking place
in is there a movie at all
i see this happening as a b story
in the eternals since zach asked me the
question this is your
b story theory this has
[Laughter]
and your whole theory is the secondary
story
to the rogue theory season finale
championships
to not go for what would be worth an a
story in a side movie
but the secondary maybe love story
[Laughter]
in the eternals all right it's pretty
rogue
uh eric would you mind taking off your
earbuds absolutely i'll tell you what
guys i wish there was an offer code
rogue25 to get 25
off these theories not free they are not
recognized it's like a great theory my
computer is
my computer is screaming from this file
how are you going to have the best of
and not be it can't be
brief i'm just yeah i'm just just and if
you want
uh if you want briefs we do have new
rockstars briefs on new
rockstarsmirch.com they're lightning
bolt briefs the same pattern
all this is true they run a little small
man they got real st they you you notice
you're wearing them
[Music]
it's not like you're wearing the that
out it's like
everything at all what uh what's the
smallest size i could buy that you think
wouldn't be medically dangerous
uh you know what we can do a custom
thing yeah let's go ahead and you and i
zoom later and i'll try a few people we
have a
new rockstar's uh flag diaper
okay
uh i do love as a as a fan of 90s uh
x-men comics i love the mojo inclusion
yes i don't think i don't think he's on
anybody's radar for future
big mcu villains so mojo is the uh mojo
is the really uh
kind uh affirming person that all of the
people watching rockstars suggest that i
should play in a marvel cinematic
university it always makes me feel very
good
it always makes me feel great when they
comment that underneath so guys make
sure you write that again
uh and i'll just continue to sit in my
sister's basement riding that exercise
bike until
you say thor uh
hey we have a uh exciting announcement
uh relating to exercise but uh we'll
save that for another video okay uh all
right uh
eric go ahead and put your earbuds back
on i do my
uh princess leia uh sign language all
right great
all right uh and then i'm gonna actually
ask the three of you to do something i
haven't seen on rogue
theory in quite a while eric uh
so starting with eric voss and we're
gonna go down the line give it to me in
a tweet
you have what sorry oh see how see what
you've done
she doesn't even know what i'm
referencing
i want to hear your entirety of your
theory
just summarized in the length of one
tweet got it
okay um mine are going to be
or my tweet is just gonna be the four
images of uh you know they do that thing
how they
they put four images together and they
all kind of work uh
in the first quadrant it is going to be
um
uh wanda vision uh sippy they're gonna
take that image of her
sipping the pepper cache but it's going
to be like puke
spilling over into uh peter parker
uh from uh into the spider verse going
like this but the puke is like hitting
his face
uh and behind him are going to be like
emo uh toby peter parker going
pizza time and then uh andrew garfield
ugly crying uh and then in the lower
quadrant
is going to be uh dr strange um
uh uh oh just like doing his thing
um but it's uh he's gonna be like
spinning the portals in that moment
where he's like you
uh is are you sure that's everyone and
then the fourth quadrant
it's going to be um uh picard
[Laughter]
yeah uh great for assessment of that i
think it was a lot of visuals that eric
gave so john
if you aren't supported of eric's theory
then john you can make that image and
help us understand it
uh and if you don't want eric to win you
don't have to make that
image uh it's up to you john his fate is
in your hands partially
uh eric uh uh sorry jessica's next all
right jessica
give it to us in a tweet um because it's
disney franchise we're gonna have a
little fun with it
it's and because of what we're doing
right here we're gonna have a little fun
with it it's gonna be set up like the
brady bunch
coroner blocks all of the superheroes
and villains are gonna be in different
ones some are angry some are confused
and it's gonna say over the poster this
is the image in it it's gonna say over
the poster
uh avengers secret wars
there you go and the tweet's going to
say
uh the tweet's going to say where yet
the whole party's here
just like the marvel uh social media
intern
who like meant to text uh some of his
boys
yeah yeah it was a draft in his tweet
folder and then he was like oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah great all right that really
summarized your theory well
uh and uh eric go ahead and uh bring it
home with uh our the last tweet on
twitter
okay last tweet on twitter ever because
this is the year that everything blows
up and ceases to exist
we'll see uh so okay mine is gonna be
in twitter format one of my favorite
memes is
you know when they're like uh how it
started and how things are going now and
it's got two pictures
so it's gonna be how it started and it's
gonna be a picture of wanda
maximoff uh splitting the whole
universe in shards with mephisto above
her
kind of with like puppet strings above
her almost like
she's pinocchio and he's gepetto and
then how it's going
is gonna be a picture full of every
single
marvel property that marvel has control
over right now
uh all running towards mephisto
with like their fists up almost like
that avengers assemble image
from event the beginning of avengers age
of ultron but you know everybody's gonna
be real teeny because they all gotta fit
in that little
1080 by 1080 box on uh instagram
gotcha we switched over to instagram
real quick there
oh sorry twitter
if i may i think i i'd like to offer my
tweet
for this whole thing is it going to
rhyme uh uh we'll find out
mephisto is a mephisto
as these experts exert their eerie
theory
it won't take long for us to make a
precision decision
with these three purists of jurists well
done tommy
[Laughter]
all right thank you as every good judge
they make it about themselves
i like beer i drink beer
yeah spur monkey dj
squeeze we went to orioles games
[Music]
all right his dad kept a calendar
stop it
i'm going to uh mute tommy in a second
but first i want
oh that that reminds me speaking of
muting right next to syracuse is
fayetteville manulis
they are a football powerhouse and right
next to that is oneonta
uh okay all right so
uh i'd like all of you three to take off
your headsets while we deliberate
no not you zack what are you doing yeah
all right uh so so what do we think i
mean
i mean it felt like an hour ago that we
heard these theories uh
i gotta say i all three excite me in
different ways
uh for me i think the most the idea of
weaving in the spider verse and how
that's gonna explain all of the
different spider-man villains is the
most compelling to me
in terms of what i want to see but i
don't know that that's the rogue
theory i mean secret wars would be so
huge right like
if they introduce secret wars like that
is
earth-shattering to the mcu so i i don't
and then silver surface would as well
but you're just throwing that in there
now
if you're signing rogies are you
imagining then what
gotta give in terms of cohesive planning
eric boss a solid amount of rogies in
terms of rogue's theory though i think
secret wars to me i mean the idea of all
of those characters there are i do think
with the big ones
your cyclopses your wolverines your
doctor dooms you don't necessarily need
a backstory that would be different than
what the mcu has done before but like
they're also with spider-man they
interestingly gave the benefit of the
doubt to the viewer didn't they they
kind of just allowed us to know who
spider-man was
i don't i wonder if they'll do something
similar with uh with the x
i'm going to give two uh two to awusu
two devos three to jessica okay
anzac see i i i feel similarity
similarly to tommy that vas obviously
has like a very well thought out
uh well researched wonderful theory if
you're talking rogue
i actually lean awasu a little bit only
because i really appreciated the
motivations that he gave the characters
both he and jessica are throwing all
kinds of new characters out as kind of
willy nilly but i love like the
motivation he gave mephisto
silver surfer ghost rider right like
even
even if we don't get multiple properties
to kind of set these characters up i
love that they hit the ground running
with like a specific directive other
than
fight the other people on the other side
of this uh battle or whatever
so i i to me he might get my
my rogies uh i'll give i'll give
thr
wow all right and then i think that i uh
you know i really appreciate all of
their their theory i think that people
went much more rogue than
usual and uh and i appreciate that
um i do think that for me i need to care
a lot about uh who we're watching on
screen the most
and i relate to humans or humanized
characters and they're only humanized
that so it's not that we need an origin
story but rather if we're watching
um silver surfer uh without an origin
story and he's fighting mephisto without
an origin source of it like we're not
really uh relating to that to that fight
very much
um so to me unfortunately that is a one
for uh erica wuzu
um for jessica i do
think that uh tommy brought up a great
point of you know
like taking us for a ride and saying
let's let's go for it
um and not have to worry about origin
stories so much i
i some people would say well isn't that
my issue with always is but
she actually um still has it anchored by
characters we do know
with at least captain america uh being
there
potentially you know another tony stark
or whatnot but these are characters that
we know and love that can kind of anchor
the experience for us
so i'm gonna give her two and then for
eric voss my
sworn enemy uh i'm going to say
that uh his brain was is designed for
these
moments and he brings such a uh
somber delivery to uh not somber but
sober
delivery to his and somberton my life uh
sober delivery 2 series that we
take them has not very rogue but they
still are uh
very rude uh and he has an answer for
everything that i throw at him i'm going
to give eric boss
three rogies
our total for yeah eric boss would be
seven for erica wusu
would be five and for jessica clemens
would be
six oh all right let's go ahead and they
can all
put their headphones back on mm-hmm
everybody give the princess leia
yeah we're back everybody do the
princess distracted myself we're never
getting jessica back
nope she's done
i'm here i'm back i was someone on was
like oh the spotify
your 2020 is up and i was looking i
can't find mine
but sorry sorry what did i miss
gotcha well you were gonna win but
unfortunately
uh you ran out of time uh we ran out of
time for the show so we don't know who
won this episode
uh guys excellent theories uh across the
board
uh excellent contributions all year
round um
eric and jessica you two have been
really great on the show and i really
feel a lot better about um not being on
the show when you guys are on we wish we
could have you back guys it's gonna be
really hard to say goodbye but this is
unfortunate
this is the end of the road for you wait
who won
wait is one of us winning and the other
getting expelled off the island like
what's going on we were very clear
whoever wins and whoever loses can get
anything they want from newark.com
cost of shipping and the retail plus
okay so uh all right
coming in third place uh with a
traditional rogi uh
he's not gonna it was everyone was doing
a point of each other uh
and uh is not even gonna bother turning
that into anything on his hand
oh yeah oh sorry yes materialized
into uh some uh contact solution
keep in contact keep in touch we'll
never see you again happy festival too
all right and uh in second place
uh getting the silver rogi which has not
made an appearance in quite a while
is uh coming in with six points total is
jessica clemons
um i'm gonna go eat the rich with it
which again the only other time it's
been given once again the golden rogi to
eric
baby hungry
take it back take it back now
olego thanos
uh eric do you have any uh parting words
as the champion
of rogue theory for 2020 the worst year
ever
ah you mother
[Laughter]
i mean he's gone further south than
binghamton new york which is just right
at the border of pennsylvania
and just a little bit okay great all
right
uh well hey eric uh jessica zacchaeus
the only one i could still talk
guys thank you so much uh for this whole
year but also thank you guys for
watching
thank you guys uh for participating uh
and the rogue theory contest on the
discord you guys are great
um that's it for this episode of rogue
theory and for
all rogue theory in 2020 thanks so much
to our guests uh
work uh you can find you guys on twitter
yo
your handles yeah i'm mostly on
instagram i feel bad for those of you
that follow me on twitter and then
message me to
keep up with my twitter i am not good on
it
i'm not good great uh so do not follow
jessica clements
not on twitter not on twitter yeah on
only fans
i don't have that either i'm sorry
you're not a fan
uh and eric yes i'm on twitter and
instagram but follow me on twitter at
owusu kid uh that's where i will tweet
and retweet
the funniest things i encounter which
are usually baby koala's falling out
trees
you can follow me on twitter proud boys
uh like hotkey keyboard thing that it
just
is set to mute tommy at a moment um
all right uh so we're gonna take a short
break on rogue theory we're gonna come
back next year with a fresh season of
rogue theory with some fun changes that
we're really excited about
to hear those changes don't forget to
subscribe to the road theory podcast
feed
stay tuned to the youtube channel for
this and other shows a really exciting
new show that we're
gonna drop in the new year that i'm
pumped about pumped up
about give you some clues there follow
us on twitter at new rockstars
i'm philip molina hey guys have a merry
holiday
i love you
eric is lying all right time to air your
grievances
one thing that's not enough
[Music]
you